[MUSIC PLAYING]
LAURENCE MORONEY: Hi, everybody,
and welcome to TensorFlow
Meets.
I'm absolutely delighted to have
my colleague Edd Wilder-James
here with me today.
Now, Edd is Mr.
Community and TensorFlow
is all about community.
So Ed, can you tell
us a little bit
about what you've been up to?
EDD WILDER-JAMES: Yeah, sure.
I have a great job,
which is I kind of
to reach out to the
whole community that's
working with in TensorFlow.
And one of the most striking
things about TensorFlow
is obviously so many places
it's used in so many areas.
And for TensorFlow to continue
to be a great project,
continue to grow,
we need to build it
so that the community can
easily be part of the thing
that we're building because
there's so many use cases.
You can't just have
the core team trying
to support them all, right?
It needs to be a sustainable
community where everyone
can help build TensorFlow
towards the use cases
that they have,
LAURENCE MORONEY: Mm-hmm
and one of the things
I find amazing is that
we talk about having
a dedication to community.
But the proof of
dedication to community
is that we have you
full time working on it.
It's like your role, right?
EDD WILDER-JAMES: It is.
And it's a tremendously
fun job to be
able to kind of help the
engineering teams out
by doing the other
part, designing
processes and designing
the groups in the same way
that an API helps
you program, right?
Some of the structures I help
build, help people interact.
LAURENCE MORONEY: That's a
really interesting analogy.
I never thought
about it that way.
That's pretty cool.
So now, you did a talk at the
TensorFlow developer summit
around community.
And there was one thing
that really jumped out,
to me, at that was that you
had a subtitle in your slide
that was saying, I think it
was, we're building TensorFlow
together--
EDD WILDER-JAMES: That's right.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Something
along those lines.
So can you tell
us really what it
means for us to be building
TensorFlow together
with the community?
EDD WILDER-JAMES: Yeah, I think,
especially in the last year,
there are two things that
help us work together
as a community.
The first of these
is that we started
to use an RFC request for
comments process for design
changes.
So a year ago, we
were at the point
where we just kind of landed
design changes in code.
Or if somebody else
wanted to contribute,
they just landed in big PR.
And there's not a lot of
transparency or discussion.
But now we've published,
I think, over 21 RFCs
where new designs for
APIs are discussed ahead
of time in public.
And it's not just the discussion
because, afterwards, that
accesses documentation.
So someone, in the future,
can come and understand
why we made these choices.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Interesting.
EDD WILDER-JAMES: That's one
way we've built together.
The second way is that
we've established,
now, six special
interest groups.
And these are very
defined project groups.
So they work on things like new
networking protocols or ways
to connect TensorFlow
to other data sources.
And these work together,
predominately community
led, to build parts
of TensorFlow.
So now, we've increased
the surface area,
increased the transparency
and the communication.
LAURENCE MORONEY:
Wow, great stuff.
So one of the things
that I always hear with--
it's easy to talk
about community.
It's hard to build community.
And one of the things to
make building community
is to try and make it easy
as possible to participate.
And I know you've been
doing lots and lots
of great work in that space.
Can you share a little bit
about some of the great things
that we have that
will help people
to participate in the community,
beyond what you've already
shared?
EDD WILDER-JAMES:
Oh, well, I'll try.
Yeah, there's a lot now.
There is a lot
more surface area.
And it really is about
surface area, right?
You walk into a big project like
TensorFlow, where do you start?
Where are the points
you can get traction?
So we, obviously-- I mentioned
that the six that are going on.
The modularity of the code
base really matters, too.
And this is one of things
we're doing in TensorFlow 2.0,
is making way more
modular, having
less in this monolithic core.
So now, you could find the
repo that you want to work on
or the developer who's
looking after that.
It's a lot more accessible.
In addition to that in code
and the six that I mentioned,
we now have a community
documentation group,
which is gaining steam, people
bringing translations on.
LAURENCE MORONEY: I've
seen the translations.
Isn't that incredible--
EDD WILDER-JAMES: Yeah, amazing.
LAURENCE MORONEY: --coming
from the community.
EDD WILDER-JAMES: Last week,
we posted up Korean and Russian
translations.
And it's fabulous to have first
class resources on our website
to those communities.
And also, finally,
the testing group
for TensorFlow 2.0, the
page [INAUDIBLE] leading,
which is really giving
people hands on time
to bash on TensorFlow
2.0 and help it,
make sure it meets all
those important use
cases that everyone has.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Right,
there's much there.
Are there any of the
community contributions
that you've seen that
particularly inspire you,
that you really like?
EDD WILDER-JAMES: Well, I think
what particularly inspires
me is the way that all
this is coming together
to support TensorFlow 2.0.
And in many ways,
it would not be
possible to do 2.0
in the way we're
doing without the community.
Let me give you an example.
All the major design, changes
we've consulted the RFC.
We now have moved a lot
of stuff out of contrib
that was existing before
and is being maintained
by community groups, the six.
That wouldn't have
been possible before.
In addition, the TensorFlow
2.0 testing group,
which is also powered by a
lot of great Google Developer
Experts, is really kind
of mashing on the APIs,
making sure they work,
but also creating
examples and notebooks that
will demo the functionality.
LAURENCE MORONEY: One
that I particularly
like is with TensorFlow
data services, the fact
that we've being able to have
contributions of data sets
from the community.
And so some of the
data sets that have
come in-- there was
one from Stanford,
an undergraduate at
Stanford University
who contributed like 200,000
chest X-ray images into a data
set.
And to make that then
easy for other people
to build training on.
It's like, without good
community, how could--
I find it inspiring.
EDD WILDER-JAMES: Yeah, exactly.
It's one half about
our attitude but also
about what we create
and structures
and also how we code things.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Right,
right, so let's switch gears
for a second.
Now, I know you're hard
at work on something
called TensorFlow World.
EDD WILDER-JAMES: Yeah.
LAURENCE MORONEY: So
it's a great name.
[LAUGHTER]
So could you tell us a
little bit about that.
EDD WILDER-JAMES:
Yeah, well, one
of the exciting things
about TensorFlow
now is that it's so widespread.
And what we wanted
to do was really
create an event that
would enable everyone
in the ecosystem to
come together to share
and to talk about
what they're doing.
Obviously, Google does some
great TensorFlow oriented
events.
But they're limited in capacity.
They're quite short.
There's a lot of
the core TensorFlow
team presenting outwards.
But there's so many
things in the world
where TensorFlow is
being used that it's
really important
for us to continue
to grow our ecosystem by
having everyone come together.
LAURENCE MORONEY: I see.
I see.
EDD WILDER-JAMES:
Well, let me give you
an example about some of the
things we'll have in there.
So it's not just talks.
But there will be tutorials.
LAURENCE MORONEY: OK.
EDD WILDER-JAMES:
There'll be training.
There'll be a chance for
software vendors who interface
with TensorFlow-- out
in the real world,
people keep all their data in
databases and clouds and other
places--
that we want to tell
their story about how
they work with TensorFlow, too.
So it'll really be
something for everybody.
LAURENCE MORONEY:
Can I go please?
EDD WILDER-JAMES:
Well, let me tell you.
Let me tell you a good
way that you could go.
Obviously, we'd love to have
everyone come and attend
as an attendee.
But right now, we have a
call for participation open--
LAURENCE MORONEY: Right.
EDD WILDER-JAMES: --which
is open until April 23.
LAURENCE MORONEY: OK.
EDD WILDER-JAMES: And
you can go to the website
URL, which is very
excitingly tensorflow.world.
LAURENCE MORONEY: OK,
I think I can remember.
EDD WILDER-JAMES: Yeah,
right, the clue's in the name.
And submit a proposal to
talk or deliver a tutorial.
And we'll be reviewing those.
And by sort of mid-May, we'll
have a schedule settled.
LAURENCE MORONEY: And where
and when is TensorFlow World?
EDD WILDER-JAMES:
Right, the conference
itself is October 28
through the 31st of October.
And that'll be in Santa Clara.
LAURENCE MORONEY: OK, so
and it's got Halloween.
EDD WILDER-JAMES: It's Halloween
and TensorFlow loves orange.
So I'm psyched.
LAURENCE MORONEY:
Exactly, it'll be great.
Are you going to
go in fancy dress?
[LAUGHTER]
Well, thanks so much.
Oh, one last question, actually.
If people want to learn
more about the community,
where can they go?
EDD WILDER-JAMES: We
decided that, again, one URL
is the best idea.
So if you go to
tensorflow.org/community,
if you just go to the
TensorFlow home page and hit
on the community label, you'll
get to all our resources.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Awesome,
awesome, OK, great.
Thanks so much.
And thanks everybody for
watching this episode
of TensorFlow Meets.
And if you've any
questions for Edd,
if you've any
questions for me, just
please leave them in
the comments below.
And all the links that
we discussed today,
I'll paste them
in there as well.
So thanks so much.
[MUSIC PLAYING]